some have famously said
sayonara
the omicron surge in new york city is
smashing single day covet case records
and now leaked emails obtained by the
new york post show health officials
admitting to prioritizing race in
distributing covet tests here to react
former nypd detective dr oscar odom i
want to begin doctor by sharing this
statement from the new york department
of health and mental hygiene this email
is just a stunner for the folks at home
who haven't had a chance to read it it
says this racial equity does not mean
simply treating everyone equally but
rather
allocating resources and services in
such a way
that explicitly addresses barriers
imposed by structural racism
and white privilege
there's so many things that can be said
about that i'm not sure where to begin i
just i i guess i would simply start by
saying this is that not racism itself
yes exactly to to put it out there that
way that definitely makes it racist you
know when i when i heard about it you
know moving the context that they had i
had viewed it from a different lens i
had viewed it from the lens of the fact
that uh because of vaccine hesitancy and
the uh low numbers of people coming out
as opposed to people coming to the
mountain you bring the mountain to them
this way you would increase more people
uh the likelihood of more people getting
the vaccine as opposed to viewing it
from that sort of lens i would not have
looked at it that way the way that it
was viewed based on that article not at
all
no you're right and listen i understand
as a public policy from a public policy
perspective you want to try to get the
word out you want to reach out to
specific communities that's fine but
when you start separating or segregating
based on the color of one's skin it just
seems preposterous to me that that could
actually be legal i'm sure there will be
some cases perhaps involving this moving
forward and by the way i'm sure you've
noticed this in your own experience
maybe you haven't i certainly have i go
to my barber shop and there's vaccine
hesitancy in the community for a very
good reason and the the best way to sort
of
address that frankly is not to simply
segregate people based on race but to
take the message to specific communities
in such a way as to convince them of the
value would you agree with that
yes i would i would agree with that that
you do that to uh show the value of what
it does and this way it makes it open to
everybody whoever may be in that
particular community to get it as
opposed to doing it based off a race but
more of vaccine hesitancy and the lower
numbers of people vaccinated in certain
areas former nypd detective doctor oscar
odom joining us let me ask you this new
york city's new mayor eric adams believe
it or not called 9-1-1 on his very first
day in office on his way to city hall
because he saw three men fighting this
actually is happening as he slams new
york city's government is being
dysfunctional for far too long in his
very first speech as mayor for those who
didn't get a chance to hear it it was
really quite something i want to just
share part of what he had to say and i
will get your reaction on the other side
here's the mayor
our government has been dysfunctional
for far too long and it created its own
crisis long before covet
whether it was crime written communities
poor schools
economic inequality or racial injustice
there's no question he's taking a not so
veiled shot there at the outgoing mayor
bill de blasio
your take on what he had to say
oh most definitely because there there
is a shot you have to look at the fact
that he's looking at it through the lens
of being a pride law enforcement officer
understanding the needs of what is
taking place and then to come out and
actually witness someone a crime taking
place right in front of his eyes and in
broad daylight shows the total disregard
for the system and the total disregard
for public safety in which people can
commit crimes in broad daylight and also
at that particular point in time
expected to get away with it and now
hopefully those things will change where
something is committed such as some sort
of act you will be
prosecuted to the fullest extent of the
law
let me switch gears and talk about
guests at a new york city quarantine
hotel believe it or not they're actually
being allowed a doctor to bring
cigarettes and marijuana
in with them now it seems apparently the
on staff nurse will then bag and weigh
and then distribute the smokes
wow how about you
i
i don't know what type of program that
is you know and and when it comes to
marijuana unfortunately unfortunately
you know everybody uh some people agree
with this some people don't agree with
it and to have it on some sort of prison
uh premise you have to look at it
because every place has some sort of
smoking policy on the premises you know
where you're not allowed to smoke in
public buildings you're not just allowed
to smoke in residential buildings
they'll have if you're going to smoke
you have to smoke outside not inside so
this type of protocol i have no idea of
what they're talking about i have no
idea why they even doing it
puff puff give can a brother get a bulb
doctor uh oscar odom really appreciate
your time today very fun conversation we
look forward to having you again
sometime soon take care
thanks thanks for having me and happy
new year hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now